Credem că calculatoarele cuantice ne vor permite să rezolvăm unele probleme mai rapid decât putem cu calculatoarele clasice singure. Dar
înțelegerea modului în care funcționează este subtilă. Astăzi, în Qiskit în clasă, vom încerca să descoperim sursa puterii
calculului cuantic uitându-ne la unul dintre primii
algoritmi. Bun venit la Qiskit în clasă. În această serie, vom folosi Qiskit pentru a explora câteva concepte fundamentale
acoperite în mod obișnuit în cursurile legate de calculul cuantic. Fiecare video este însoțit de un modul interactiv
legat în descrierea de mai jos. Deci, asigură-te că îl verifici. Dacă ai auzit multe despre calculatoarele cuantice, probabil ai
auzit că pot folosi fenomene cuantice precum superpozitia, entanglementul și interferența pentru a rezolva
probleme în moduri în care calculatoarele clasice nu pot. Dar cum anume ajută aceste caracteristici? În 1985, David Deutsch a fost
primul care a arătat cum se poate întâmpla asta. El a venit cu ceea ce se numește acum algoritmul lui Deutsch, care putea rezolva o
problemă mai eficient decât un algoritm clasic. Astăzi, vom arunca o privire la algoritmul lui Deutsch și
la o extensie ulterioară numită algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa și vom examina cum aspectele cuantice unice ale qubit-urilor
pot fi folosite în beneficiul calculatoarelor cuantice. Apoi vom rula acești algoritmi pe un calculator cuantic real cu Qiskit.
Există și alți algoritmi cuantici care demonstrează un avantaj teoretic față de algoritmii clasici cunoscuți. Și nu toți funcționează
pe aceleași principii ca cele pe care le vom vedea astăzi. Deci ce vom învăța astăzi nu explică în general cum funcționează un calculator cuantic,
dar ne ajută să începem să vedem cum principiile mecanicii cuantice pot fi combinate pentru a
crea un calculator cuantic puternic. Înainte de a ne aprofunda în algoritmul lui Deutsch, să ne gândim mai întâi cum calculatoarele cuantice
sunt diferite de calculatoarele clasice și cum ar putea asta să ne ofere un avantaj în rezolvarea anumitor
probleme. O diferență este că biții cuantici numiți qubit-uri pot fi în stări de superpozitie. În loc să fie
limitați fie la starea zero, fie la starea unu, cum este un bit clasic, un qubit
poate fi într-o stare de superpozitie a ambelor stări zero și unu. Scriem această stare astfel:
unde a și b sunt numere complexe ale căror pătrate se adună la unu și cu cât mai mulți
qubit-uri, cu atât mai mult se extinde acest decalaj. Doi biți pot fi în continuare doar într-una dintre aceste
patru stări posibile. 0 0 1 1 0 sau 1
1. Doi qubit-uri pot fi într-o superpozitie a tuturor celor patru stări permise clasic, ceea ce se
scrie astfel. În general, un sistem clasic de n biți poate fi doar în una dintre cele 2 la puterea n combinații posibile
de zerouri și unuri. Un sistem cuantic de n qubit-uri poate fi într-o superpozitie a tuturor celor 2 la puterea n dintre aceste
stări. Scalarea este exponențială. Deci, chiar dacă am avea doar 10 qubit-uri, ele
ar putea fi într-o stare de superpozitie de 2 la puterea 10, adică 1.024 de combinații posibile de zerouri și
unuri. Scalarea exponențială a spațiului de stări al qubit-urilor se numește paralelism cuantic
și este parțial responsabilă de avantajul calculatoarelor cuantice față de calculatoarele clasice. Dar un calculator cuantic
nu este doar un procesor masiv paralel. Simplul fapt că qubit-urile dintr-un calculator cuantic pot fi într-o
superpozitie a unui număr exponențial de stări nu înseamnă că avem acces la toate informațiile din fiecare dintre aceste
stări. Deoarece măsurarea prăbușește sistemul într-o stare sau alta, să
vedem cum se manifestă asta într-o problemă simplă. Să spunem că există o mașinărie căreia
îi poți furniza un singur bit. Apoi va aplica o funcție bitului și va scoate un alt bit. Mașinăria
se află într-o cutie neagră la care nu avem acces. Tot ce avem acces este bitul
pe care îl furnizăm x și bitul pe care cutia îl scoate f
din x. Vrem să aflăm care este funcția f pe care o aplică mașinăria.
Există patru funcții posibile care duc un bit la un alt bit.
Deci, pentru a afla care este funcția, putem să îi furnizăm un zero și să vedem dacă scoate un zero sau un unu. Apoi să îi furnizăm
un unu și să facem același lucru. Fiecare dintre acești doi pași se numește interogare. Aceasta
este o modalitate de a compara algoritmii clasici și cuantici prin intermediul așa-numitului model de interogare, unde comparăm numărul
de interogări pe care fiecare dintre algoritmi trebuie să le facă cutiei negre pentru a rezolva problema. Deci, în acest caz,
metoda noastră clasică a trebuit să interogheze cutia de două ori pentru a afla funcția. Să vedem dacă putem face mai bine dacă avem un calculator cuantic
care interoghează cutia neagră. În loc să furnizăm mai întâi un zero și apoi un unu,
calculatorul cuantic poate furniza cutiei un qubit care se află în superpozitie de zero și
unu. Deci, în esență, furnizăm cutiei ambele intrări cu o singură interogare. Atunci
înseamnă asta că putem afla funcția cu o singură interogare?
Din păcate, nu este cazul. Vedem de ce această idee eșuează când o testăm pe un calculator cuantic. Vom face un
circuit cu doi qubit-uri. Qubit zero reprezentat aici prin această linie de sus va fi starea noastră de intrare X pe care o furnizăm
cutiei negre, care era arătată aici prin gate-ul maron etichetat UF. Gate-ul UF este
conceput pentru a lua qubit zero ca stare de intrare X, apoi a aplica o transformare pe qubit unu care ia
starea zero la starea f din x. Deci, atâta timp cât qubit 1 a pornit din starea
zero, atunci ieșirea este x pe qubit 0 și f din x pe qubit 1. Deci, pentru a găsi f din x pentru
atât x=0 cât și x=1 simultan, putem încerca să punem qubit 0 în superpozitie de 0 și 1 înainte
să îl furnizăm cutiei negre. Aceasta se face cu acest gate Hadamard roșu care transformă starea zero la 1/√2
0 + 1. Deci, după gate-ul cutiei negre, ar trebui să avem acum o superpozitie a ambelor
f din 0 și f din 1 pe qubit 1. Când măsurăm cei doi qubit-uri, sperăm să
răspundem la întrebarea, ce funcție se află în cutia neagră. Să folosim primitiva sampler din Qiskit pentru a rula
circuit-ul și a returna rezultatul. Putem alege numărul de ori de câte ori circuit-ul este rulat, numite mostre, modificând acest
parametru numit shots aici.
WEBVTT
Acesta este echivalentul numărului de interogări pe care le facem cutiei negre. Să vedem dacă o singură interogare va
funcționa. Iată rezultatul. Am măsurat qubit 0 ca fiind zero. Deci acesta a fost
valoarea de intrare x, iar qubit 1 a fost 1, care a fost valoarea de ieșire f din x. Deci acum
știm că f din 0 este egal cu 1. Dar ce se întâmplă cu f din 1? Aici este problema. Odată ce
am măsurat starea, superpozițiile s-au prăbușit și am putut măsura doar o parte a funcției cu o
singură interogare. Aceasta nu ne spune tot ce trebuie să știm pentru a determina care este funcția. Am avea nevoie de o
a doua interogare a cutiei pentru aceasta. Deci, chiar dacă principiul paralelismului cuantic ne permite să
facem ca cutia neagră să evalueze simultan f din 0 și f din 1, nu avem acces la ambele
răspunsuri. Paralelismul cuantic singur nu este suficient. Algoritmul lui Deutsch
arată cum putem folosi paralelismul cuantic puțin diferit pentru a afla despre funcția din cutia neagră. Nu vom
putea afla exact care este funcția, dar vom putea afla ceva nou despre ea cu o
singură interogare, ceea ce nu am putea face cu un calculator clasic. Să începem prin a ne uita la un grafic al celor patru funcții posibile
care duc un bit la un alt bit. Aici poți vedea că două dintre funcții, f_sub_1 și f_sub_4, returnează mereu
o singură valoare indiferent de starea de intrare. Numim aceste două funcții
constante. f_sub_2 și f_sub_3 vor returna fie zero, fie unu în funcție de
starea lui x. Numim aceste două funcții echilibrate. Algoritmul lui Deutsch
determină dacă funcția este constantă sau echilibrată prin câteva ajustări inteligente ale circuit-ului pe care l-am folosit
înainte. Iată circuit-ul. Începe prin pregătirea qubit 0 în starea 1 /
√2 0 + 1 cu un Hadamard ca înainte și qubit 1 în starea 1 / √2 0 - 1
cu un gate not urmat de un Hadamard.
Deci starea completă în acest punct este unde aceasta este starea qubit 0 și
aceasta este starea qubit 1. Pregătirea qubit unu în acest mod, mai degrabă decât simpla
lăsare a lui în starea zero, permite algoritmului să folosească paralelismul cuantic în combinație cu interferența pentru a afla
despre funcția din cutia neagră. Să vedem cum, atunci când qubit-urile sunt introduse în UF, gate-ul cutiei negre, pot
apărea câteva lucruri. Dacă funcția este constantă, atunci cutia neagră va efectua o operație pe qubit unu singur, indiferent
de starea lui zero. În acest caz, deoarece UF nu atinge qubit zero și
nu îi pasă deloc de starea lui, atunci al doilea Hadamard de aici anulează ce a
făcut primul Hadamard. Și vom măsura qubit-ul ca fiind în starea zero. Să ne uităm la funcția echilibrată f_sub_2 ca exemplu pentru a vedea
ce face UF stării în acest caz. Când x este zero, f din x este zero și când x
este 1, f din x este 1. Reamintește-ți ce ți-am spus despre gate-ul UF. Ia qubit 0
ca starea noastră de intrare x și scoate f din x pe qubit 1, presupunând că qubit 1
a pornit din starea zero. Deci, pentru această funcție, ce face UF qubit-ului 1 depinde
de qubit 0. Dacă 0 este zero atunci qubit 1 va fi lăsat în starea zero pentru a obține f
din x = 0. Dacă qubit 0 este 1, cutia neagră va aplica un gate not qubit-ului 1 și îl va pune
în starea unu. Deci obținem f din 1 egal cu 1. Acesta este exact ceea ce face un gate controlled-NOT sau gate CNOT. Un
gate CNOT ia doi qubit-uri, un qubit de control și un qubit țintă, și schimbă
starea qubit-ului țintă dacă qubit-ul de control este în starea unu. Dar nu face nimic qubit-ului țintă dacă qubit-ul de control
este în starea zero. Deci UF pentru F2 este doar un CNOT pe Q0 și Q1. Gate-ul C
NOT nu va face nimic primului termen, deoarece qubit-ul de control este în starea zero. Dar pe al doilea termen, acest
zero se schimbă în unu și acest unu se schimbă în zero. Și dacă factorizăm un semn minus, vom vedea că starea qubit-ului 1 este
neschimbată. Dar acest termen a preluat un semn minus. Deci starea qubit-ului 0 este
de fapt cea care s-a schimbat. A trecut de la a fi 0 + 1 la a fi 0 minus
unu. Când aplicăm Hadamard-ul final qubit-ului 0, acesta îl transformă în starea 1. Deci dacă funcția din cutia neagră
este f_sub_2, vom măsura un unu în loc de un zero. Se dovedește că gate-ul UF pentru cealaltă funcție echilibrată f3 este
același gate CNOT urmat de un not pe qubit 1. Acel gate not final nu afectează qubit zero. Deci când funcția
este echilibrată, vom măsura qubit 0 ca fiind în starea unu la sfârșitul circuit-ului. Acum dacă nu ai urmărit tot
aceasta, este în regulă. Îți sugerez să parcurgi asta pe cont propriu pentru a vedea cum funcționează. Punctul major de reținut este ce
s-a întâmplat când am aplicat gate-ul CNOT pentru cele două funcții echilibrate. Qubit 0 a fost folosit doar ca qubit de control pentru a schimba
starea qubit-ului 1. Intuitiv, ai putea crede că qubit 0 ar rămâne neschimbat. Și totuși, cumva,
operațiile pe qubit unu schimbă de fapt starea qubit-ului zero schimbând faza relativă dintre cele două părți ale
superpozitiei sale. Acest fenomen este cunoscut sub numele de mecanismul de phase kickback și este
extrem de contraintuitiv, la fel ca multe fenomene cuantice. Într-un anumit sens, poți te gândi la mecanismul de phase kickback
ca la vâslitul unei bărci. Actul de a împinge apa înapoi te propulsează de fapt înainte. La fel cum operațiile pe
qubit 1 schimbă de fapt qubit zero. Acum putem rula algoritmul lui Deutsch pe
Qiskit. Aici putem selecta ce funcție să punem în cutia neagră, pe care am ales-o a fi F3. Iată
diagrama circuit-ului algoritmului și îl putem rula ca înainte cu primitiva sampler. Vom seta numărul de
mostre la doar una și vom vedea ce măsurăm. În acest caz, am măsurat unu.
Deci știm că funcția a fost echilibrată, ceea ce este într-adevăr ceea ce ne-am așteptat, deoarece cutia neagră conținea funcția f3. Deci, cu o singură
interogare, am putut face diferența între aceste două clase de funcții.
Un algoritm clasic ar fi necesitat două interogări pentru a determina asta. Aceasta arată un avantaj modest al
calculului cuantic față de calculul clasic, dar nu este prea impresionant. Doar unu versus doi. Dar algoritmul lui Deutsch
WEBVTT
este totuși extrem de important pentru istoria calculului cuantic, deoarece a oferit scânteia care i-a făcut pe alții
să se gândească la algoritmi cuantici mai mari și mai sofisticați.
Aceasta include o extensie cu mai mulți qubit-uri a algoritmului lui Deutsch care demonstrează un avantaj cuantic mult mai impresionant.
Aceasta se numește algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa. Rezolvă o problemă similară, dar în acest caz, funcția din cutia neagră
pe care vrem să o cunoaștem ia n biți ca intrare și scoate un singur bit. Ca
înainte, ni se garantează că funcția este fie constantă, adică bitul de ieșire este mereu unu sau mereu zero,
indiferent de șirul de biți de intrare, fie echilibrată, adică ieșirea este zero pentru
jumătate din șirurile de biți de intrare și unu pentru cealaltă jumătate. Există, desigur, alte
funcții care duc n biți la un singur bit, care nu sunt nici constante, nici echilibrate. Dar în această problemă, ni se
garantează că niciuna dintre acele funcții nu se află în cutia neagră. Cea din cutie este garantat a fi fie constantă
fie echilibrată. Circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa arată similar cu algoritmul lui Deutsch, dar cu mai mulți qubit-uri. Aici avem o
implementare a algoritmului Deutsch-Jozsa pentru a afla despre o funcție cu trei biți. De data aceasta avem trei qubit-uri
pentru starea de intrare, nu doar unul. Și apoi avem acest ultim qubit pentru starea de ieșire. Ca înainte, din nou
pregătim toți qubit-urile de intrare să fie în starea 0 + unu și qubit-ul de ieșire
să fie în starea 0 minus unu. Deși matematica este puțin mai complicată de urmărit, principiul
rămâne același. Dacă funcția este constantă, nu va depinde de primii trei qubit-uri deloc. Deci stările lor
se vor transforma înapoi la zero după al doilea Hadamard și măsurarea noastră va da un șir de trei biți cu toți
zerouri. Dar dacă funcția este echilibrată, atunci când măsurăm qubit-urile după aplicarea Hadamard-urilor, mecanismul de phase kickback
va face ca unul sau mai mulți dintre acei biți să fie unu. S-ar putea să nu fie atât de ușor de văzut de data aceasta, dar dacă parcurgi
fiecare pas pe cont propriu, vei vedea curând că acesta trebuie să fie cazul. O modalitate de a verifica este să încerci să calculezi
probabilitatea de a măsura toți zerouri cu o funcție echilibrată. Ar trebui să obții o probabilitate de zero. Să rulăm
algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa pe un calculator cuantic cu Qiskit. Cel mai dificil pas este probabil crearea funcției Deutsch-Jozsa.
Aceea va fi cutia noastră neagră pe care o interogăm aici. Acest cod produce o funcție Deutsch-Jozsa aleatorie care este
garantat a fi fie echilibrată, fie constantă. Apoi construim circuit-ul nostru Deutsch-Jozsa inserând cutia noastră neagră
funcție aici. Din nou, rulăm circuit-ul cu sampler și după ce măsurăm, ne uităm la
biții măsurați pentru a determina dacă funcția a fost echilibrată sau constantă.
Dacă toți sunt zero, este constantă. Dar dacă există cel puțin un bit unu în șir, atunci este echilibrată. În acest
caz, obținem un șir de biți de 1 unu unu.
Deci, știm că funcția a fost echilibrată. Sper că ți-am oferit prima ta privire asupra modului în care algoritmii cuantici
pot profita de fenomene cuantice interesante și adesea subtile pentru a obține avantajul lor față de algoritmii clasici.
Probabil ai observat și cât de dificil poate fi să proiectezi algoritmi cuantici. Chiar primul
a necesitat multă creativitate pentru a obține o victorie modestă față de metodele clasice. Și de la primul algoritm,
fizicienii și informaticienii au continuat să găsească modalități incredibil de inventive de a folosi mecanica cuantică
în avantajul lor, inclusiv extensii și aplicații suplimentare ale algoritmului Deutsch-Jozsa. Dacă vrei să
afli despre unele dintre acestea, precum și să încerci algoritmii Deutsch și Deutsch-Jozsa pe cont propriu, accesează
modulul legat în descriere pentru a începe. Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare.